hi in this video I will talk about flip
ever artery system in Drosophila
so flip refer t system is a genetic
technique by which we can make genetic
mosaics why do we need genetic mosaics
it should be clear during this video
using flip a faulty system one can make
neutral to homozygous cell in otherwise
heterozygous background and thereby it
can make it can produce a mosaic so flip
every system is based on side directed
recombination so let's talk about the
utility of this kind of system before
that let's say we have our gene of
interest and in order to know whether
this gene is what is the gene product or
which physiological process is
associated with this kind of gene what
we can do we can make mutant and then
study the physiological stuff is the
processes that has an imperturbable not
mutant or what phenotype that mutant has
classical way of generating mutant is
either p element imprecise excision or
by ems mutagenesis but there is a
problem with this kind of mutations if
this gene of interest that we are
interested in if it is associated with
development then it might happen that
the flying layer eggs or the lay the
eggs never come out and and we don't get
an adult fly at a mutant fly but we
wanted to study the behavior at the
adult so let's say we wanted to study a
adult behavior all right al olfaction or
how that is behaved but we cannot do it
because the larvae or pupae doesn't
manage to the adult so now we are stuck
at this point so it's a solution we can
use mitotic clone or we can use flip a
party system to make mosaics but in the
adult a pool of cells will be mutant not
all of the cells a pool of cells will be
mutant and in in a background of
heterozygous sense heterozygous
wild-type cells now let's see how how p
have faced these kind of problems and
how they have solved it
so here I am talking about a problem
where people have people have people are
using RNA or a best approach to find new
genes which could be important for
development they used so Sevilla is a
genetic model they found this ship one
protein could be important player for
development because as when they knock
down this protein they have a overgrowth
in the eyes now as a result they have
validated their eye RNA and then they
went on to make mutant mutant of this
particular gene they used P element
imprecise excision which is a classical
way of making mutant but there is a big
problem because a huge chunk of that
particular gene was deleted and as a
result the they become embryonic lethal
or lethal app or they die at very early
larval stages so the while so the adult
fly never come out how do they study
this when the error fly is not there so
the way they could start it is is by
making genetic mosaics or making mitotic
loans using flip a party system now in
fly several organs like wing eyes these
are attractive places where people
usually make mutants here I would
discuss how people can use I as a mosaic
system so here you can see there are
some cells marked here in white which
are muted and they are in a background
of otherwise wild-type cells now how to
make that in order to make that we we
induce mitotic recombination so
recombination generally happens during
meiosis but you can induce recombination
using this flip recombinase now flip
recombinase can only combine at a site
where if RT is present so flip finds 240
and induce recombination now what we can
do during replication just after
replication we can induce
we can induce FLP expression so as a
result FFP would induce
combination and we could get wild type 2
in spot clone which has this is the wild
type 2 in splat two spots tone which has
this white marker that's why it is red
in color but whereas the mutant is
unmarked
it has mutation in homozygous condition
so in the whole fly we have produced
mutant cell and also two in sport clone
cells which are wild-type so you know by
light background we have generated
mutant cells and now we can study the
characteristics of these cells how
they're interacting with the other cells
or how several phenomena is happening in
these cells so the organism is not dead
because we have mutated at specific
location of the eyes not the whole
organism so that's why the whole
organism is not dead now you can control
the FLP expression using heat-shock
promoters or you can use two specific
promoters for spatial specifications or
special control so that is how we can
make a genetic mosaic and thanks for
watching my video if you like my video
give it a quick thumbs up please like
subscribe and share thank you